and then just the french 18 marcusstraat
there is tile eswin is camping with former us
president donald trump i have another covert
restrictions de lier of die en thay
immigration populus party jerry buddha
is tryin to attract photos by king
buy it nineteen
common floor and premium international
conspiracy  for being bihain the pandemic
anders of people at and grandma there in the
hospital right suffering from corona many
people in a lifetime more than
15,000 series issued
that they know normal number four serious floor
who has the net for thousands of years and
spacious complete has'  plus or
felt I can buy the will
do stories poor there go you dispute the
platform horse confessed let your sister two
years ago with fierce part-up a race is
an anti-semitic messages for my
audience there's that mood in the
growing  sentiment best-known lockdown we
the american style can pay day
conspiracy theory
effect to media
sentiment in the approaching guns lockdown
tedkroon the spe  cially after night time
curfew was introduced in january
where you ghost old and dairy city's
and buy testing facilities were
attacked
for iparty grind for democracy
appear to be jobs fitting of this end
i can't go no more we stand where i
cramp go anywhere i want  you and i
defining gel
if you have the freedom there is my take no
way from as en der a score higher picked up
the fire terrible freedom and like
maria de boats free dan hans Kool stereo
am and tear me shake and me in
burleigh follow usually i  was it already
online as mais
[Applause]
waalboer des parties poland grand prix
percent of the foto another en tmi
creation party the freedom party of geert
wilders is predicted to win a lone twin
types are at the can the second largest
watch this for you ziggo
versa met nefarious builds immigration of
islam it's about romi
yes there is an ami sign responsible view
de alse walloon people because you really
unfollow en
en de in the public health as well  the mad
king third big issue
the problem of you it's not about
immigration is where i asked the percent
not bite single response profile that a
wheel of benefits around the british that is
not place you want to benefit from the
pandemic mdf precisely by margin at his
sound system i a few on the gave him
a dat slim
since know where i want to give him
because of his youth and immigration and
islam
koen vossen brighter of the book about
wilders his tripods by antoine
shift on the dutch electric photo for fun
ride patisse  the influence belt a
smart dit in de to a station tand
polders the middle finger photo
shell people who piece of middle finger to
the political establishment and they want
to shop the establishment and how can
you shop the establishment by choosing
sombody cool is oh shocking de d
politicians in the stain
and that's what wilders keeps my
questions' successful campaigns
oil based on buy it restrictions will
be what many in the netherlands  nd avada it
's already two large group how do I
divider ganttify rest
seriously
we read my doctor for this form for the
milk kcs mile end israeli and not you
can probably sea if necessary social
distance in here n roll en emergency zo
nobodies farmer jenny but it can
offer tassel what loss wants to do is
a large police force cold here
and why 2 days before the elections in
the infection therapy and the late
nou bob of infections number of
infection since and jerry
boer count it yesterday so that if there is
such a chance there  an already dead redraw
love of measures to make the collections
at cps possible be
built white growing on wednesday
when lexi swallow take place great
staff was there was about live of
the headset funky very much a date